mai lag hat die eine million abonnenten
geknackt und ich frage mich wie mein
ernst ich möchte heute versuchen zu
analysieren wie das passieren konnte
ich möchte einfach ein bisschen meine
erfahrungen teilen und vielleicht helfen
diese erfahrungen anderen creator oder
jedem der versucht bereich weiter
aufzubauen aber erstmal danke danke
danke freude der sonne wenn ihr wüsstet
wie oft sie im team darüber reden dass
wir einfach die beste community haben
und ich weiß jeder user über denkt dass
er die beste community hat aber ich habe
das sorgfältig recherchiert und ihr seid
die beste community und die community
ist ja immer ein wesentlicher teil eines
kanals ohne euch wäre ich nur eine frau
die alleine mit einer kamera spricht
deswegen sprechen wir heute mal ein
bisschen über reichweitenaufbau und das
internet ist ja eigentlich voll von
tipps wie man mehr abonnenten auf
youtube bekommt und viele davon sind
sogar auch total vernünftig also wie man
titel und sammle auswählt jemand
community management macht wie man kanal
trailer erstellt und natürlich auch sehr
wichtig der youtube algorithmus was
möchte er bevorzugt er gerade kürzere
oder doch wieder längere videos und so
weiter aber mit meile habe ich die
erfahrung gemacht dass man manchmal
genau das gegenteil davon machen muss
was so alles regel für den
reichweitenaufbau gilt und eine
reichweite aufzubauen also wir haben
manche sachen falsch gemacht die dann am
ende aber genau richtig waren und was es
genau war das will ich euch heute
verraten deswegen holt euch einen tee
und jetzt habe ich hier konnten macht es
euch gemütlich wir steigen durch
ich kann hier natürlich nur meine
persönlichen einschätzungen teilen es
gibt ja nicht so was wie eine
funktionierende standard anleitung wie
man eine million abonnenten bekommt es
gibt ja so keine geld zurück garantie
sobald das video auch nichts kostet ich
habe drei punkte die so ein bisschen
gegen die regeln gehen
punkt eins seht euch nicht als youtuber
als ich ein kind war wollten die meisten
tierärztin oder feuerwehrmann werden
heutzutage wollen immer mehr kinder
später mal youtuber werden und das löst
bei manchen direkt sowas aus wie früher
war alles besser aber youtuber sein zu
wollen ist nicht grundsätzlich schlecht
oder gut ich bin youtube
ich mache videos auf youtube deswegen
bin ich eine youtube drin aber ich bin
es nur unter anderem oder nur in zweiter
linie
wenn ich denke gute youtuber also
darunter verstehe ich menschen die guten
inhalt machen sind in erster linie
musiker oder entertain comedians
sportler köche seelsorger make up artist
journalisten wie auch immer und youtube
ist nur die plattform auf der man seine
inhalte hochlädt und ich bin in erster
linie wissenschaftskommunikatoren oder
wissenschaftsjournalistin und es wegen
möchte ich auch youtube in sein damit
ich möglichst viele menschen erreichen
deswegen liebe kinder berufswunsch
youtuber ist völlig in ordnung aber die
eigentlich wichtige frage ist was für
ein youtube zweitens denkt an die
reichweite als letztes zumindest weil
ich das durch mai lab gelernt und zwar
eilig wurde im september 2016 gegründet
da ist der kanal noch nicht mal app
sondern wir waren ein kleines team das
stativ melanie die grafikerin und ich
dieser kanal war schon immer ein
öffentlich-rechtlicher kanal mal app ist
teil von funk aber dieser kanal wurde
auch schon immer produziert wie ein
privater kanal auch wenn das manche
niemals glauben werden
hallo frau merkel ja natürlich können
wir die nächsten videos besprechen
sollen wir suchen
ich hatte auf diesem kanal also schon
immer alle freiheiten und schön schlau
war auch total main kanal also ich habe
es auch immer geliebt ich habe nur nicht
unbedingt die videos gemacht die ich
auch selbst sehen würde sondern ich habe
versucht videos zu machen von denen ich
glaubte dass sie möglichst vielen
anderen menschen gefallen es ging um
astronauten und darüber dass sie im
weltraum nicht trösten können ohne zu
kotzen wie ihr wisst schon sein und ich
habe mich auch in meiner tätigkeit
zurückgehalten kurz sollten die videos
seien so kurz wie möglich ist sollte
sich ja keiner langweilen wir wollten
auch niemanden verschrecken ihr wisst
schon sein start war jetzt nicht
unbedingt unerfolgreich würde ich sagen
schlauer hatte jetzt 10.000 abonnenten
was sagen sie dazu
wie kam man nicht so richtig vom fleck
wir versuchten alle tipps und regeln die
man so kennt zum beispiel aktuelle
events aufgreifen dass man zum
oktoberfest ein video über alkohol macht
und zum valentinstag ein video über
küssen oder kollaborationen mit größeren
kanälen aber nichts davon ging so
wirklich durch die decke
doch dann passierte das ihr hier seht
ihr die aufruf zahlen von diesem kanal
vom zeitpunkt der gründung bis heute
es gibt ein paar ausnahme events also
ihr seht ihr eine babypause zum beispiel
oder dass ihr war das kroner geht gerade
erst los video das er so ein bisschen
die ral gegangen ist aber grundsätzlich
geht es langsam und stetig nach oben
jetzt schaut man genauer hin hier wurde
das erste video hochgeladen die aufrufe
waren anderthalb jahre lang einfach so
niedrig dass es so aussieht als hätte
der kanal vor 2018 gar nicht existiert
was ist also hier passiert war das
zufall also hat sich der youtube
algorithmus umgestellt oder so klar dass
möglich aber ich bin davon überzeugt
dass der hauptgrund ein anderer war
nämlich ende 2017 anfang 2018
beschlossen wie ihr schön schlau neu zu
denken und wir versucht und den kanal
noch mehr zu meinem zu machen unter
anderem beschlossen wir auch den namen
zu ändern was wir dann im april 2018
offiziell gemacht haben schön schlau
wurde meine wir haben uns für diese zeit
so eine art findungsphase gegönnt in der
ich so ein bisschen herumprobiert habe
und versucht herauszufinden was für
inhalte will ich eigentlich wirklich
machen und was wir content würde ich
auch gerne sehen
und jetzt kommt damit ich diese
findungsphase nicht kreativ oder
innerlich eingeschränkt bin beschlossen
wir und wir wurden auch von funk
explizit dazu ermutigt eben nicht auf
die zahlen zu schauen und die themen
nicht danach auszurichten was jetzt viel
geteilt werden könnte oder was viele
abos gibt sondern nur noch danach was
sie spannend finde das war eine
befreiung und diese befreiung hatte drei
gute folgen erstens die videos machten
wir noch mehr spaß und ich glaube das
publikum spürt so was zweitens die
videos wurden authentischer und ich
glaube auch dafür hat man als zuschauer
ein ganz gutes gefühl
und drittens die videos wurden inhalt
nicht besser weil ich mich einfach nicht
mehr darauf
ich habe eine gute youtube drin zu sein
sondern darauf was ich eigentlich
besonders gut kann nämlich abmelden und
wir haben nicht damit gerechnet dass es
so viele freunde der sonne da draußen
gibt die von anfang an mit gehen das
hier war also eine echte überraschung
und ich weiß was sehr genau
als 100.000 abonnenten hatten dachte
schon alter nie gedacht dass so etwas
überhaupt möglich ist paradoxerweise
also ging die abos und views genau dann
ab als wir aufhörten uns über abos und
views gedanken zu machen weil das
zumindest in meinem fall mich davon
abgehalten hatte den bestmöglichen
content zu machen gleichzeitig sind wir
ein abo es natürlich eine riesige
motivation um bestmöglichen content zu
machen genau das ist auch wieder so
tricky daran denn obwohl es natürlich am
ende die zuschauer sind den kanal groß
oder erfolgreich machen sollte man sich
als creator nicht zu viel oder zu früh
mit reichweitenaufbau beschäftigen denn
all diese allgemeingültigen tipps zum
reichweite
eltex algorithmus tipps die bringen ja
nichts wenn ihr keinen guten content
habt der content ist ja die
voraussetzung wenn ihr euren
bestmöglichen content habt ja dann könnt
ihr müsst ihr sogar euch gedanken um die
reichweite machen denn es wäre total
schade wenn die ganze arbeit und die
guten inhalte von niemandem gesehen
werden also macht euch gedanken um die
reichweite aber eben erst als letztes
drittens macht weniger videos und mehr
pausen es heißt man soll bei youtube
regelmäßig hochladen er youtube
algorithmus mindestens einmal die woche
am besten mehr und möglichst keine pause
machen wir haben hier immer mal wieder
pause gemacht sommerpause zum beispiel
das machen noch relativ viele youtuber
weil die sommerzeit nicht so eine gute
youtube zeit ist bei viele tausend sind
oder im urlaub sind und so weiter wir
haben aber auch winterpause gemacht
wovon abgeraten wird bald winzer eine
gute youtube zeit ist und wir haben
unter anderem winter auch eine
monatelange babypause gemacht aber jede
einzelne pause war gut für diesen kanal
dann keine abos verloren und auch die
views sind anschließend nicht
eingebrochen sondern haben
meistens sogar zugelegt vielleicht liegt
es einfach nur daran dass ihr die bässe
community sollte da haben wir es wieder
außerdem kommt mein letzter diesem jahr
nur noch alle zwei wochen und nicht jede
woche weil wir so langer und
sorgfältiger recherchieren können und
mehr recherche heißt gleichzeitig auch
mehr zeit am skript denn je komplexer
ein thema ist desto mehr muss man sich
den kopf darüber zerbrechen wie man das
ganze jetzt verständlich aber immer noch
korrekt vermittelt weniger videos zu
machen erlaubt uns bessere videos zu
machen oder zumindest findet ihr sie
besser denn die meisten abonnenten haben
wir dieses jahr bekommen mit diesem zwei
wochen rhythmus und ich verstehe wenn
ihr kleinere creator seite könnt ihr es
euch nicht leisten weniger videos zu
machen oder pausen weil ihr euch erst
mal eine sichtbarkeit und eine community
auf baum ist aber wisst ihr was euch
definitiv noch weniger leisten könnt
schlechten content gerade wenn ihr noch
im aufbau seid also ein video das
ausfällt weil es nicht schafft wird euch
weniger schaden als ein schlechtes video
das heißt egal was ihr schafft an
quantität macht es nie auf kosten der
qualität so das waren jetzt drei tipps
gegen die regel ich habe aber noch einen
sehr wichtigen punkt 4 und sucht euch
ein gutes team oft wird falsch
eingeschätzt werde ich genau hinter
meine besteht aber frau merkel manche
denken ich mache das ganz alleine andere
denken ich hab ein riesiges
professionelles team hinter mir
die wirklichkeit sieht so aus die
produktion dieser videos ist sehr
klassisch youtube also ich bin hier zu
hause
die kamera steht auf einem stativ und
den schnitt den mache ich auch selbst
hier an diesem schreibtisch heißt ich
muss gleich staubsaugen die eigentliche
produktion der videos ist also sehr
homepage buchstäblich aber die
produktion ist relativ gesehen nur der
kleinste teil hinter einem eilig video
steckt sehr viel mehr arbeit und da will
ich euch einen kleinen blick hinter die
kulissen geben als web team besteht aus
vier menschen erstens melanie bekannt
als die meile grafikerin ist redakteurin
beim swr und sie ist diejenige die mich
2016 entdeckt und für funk rekrutiert
hat melanie macht beim swr und für
funkel noch andere sachen also mein tipp
ist jetzt nicht ihr einziges ding aber
mein tipp ist melanies und mein baby
weil wir meine wirklich von null auf
großgezogen haben melanies nicht nur
eine sehr gute grafikerin sondern mit
ihr bespreche ich auch alle themen also
sie ist in der redaktion
die nicht unwichtige nicht
wissenschaftliche stimme die unter
anderem sicherstellt dass ich mich nicht
in irgendwelchen nerd blasen verliere
aber sie ist auch ein sehr sympathischer
mensch mit einer hohen emotionalen und
sozialen kompetenz die ich sehr zu
schätzen weiß und gerade wenn man
wissenschaftliche inhalte macht darf man
nicht vergessen vor lauter zahlen und
daten die menschen auch mit ihren
emotionen abzuholen und das kann melanie
sehr gut darüber hinaus hätten die
männer die den rücken frei denn rund um
so einen kanal geht es auch ganz viele
organisatorische dinge die nicht direkt
mit den eigentlichen inhalten zu tun
haben und die fängt melanie auch für
mich ab so dass ich mich eben auf das
inhaltliche konzentrieren können 2018
habe ich dann lars kennengelernt last
trägt bei uns im team den liebevollen
spitznamen vieler fuchs weil niemand so
akribisch gut darin ist skripte nach
fehlern und kleinsten ungenauigkeiten
durch zu fixen vilas also wir arbeiten
beim alb nach dem wissenschaftlichen
prinzip der falsifizieren das bedeutet
wir suchen nicht nur belege für unsere
aussagen sondern wir versuchen auch fast
schon manisch unsere aussagen zu
widerlegen um zu schauen ob sie den
widerlegung instand halten dass ich las
gefunden habt war einfach nur ein großes
glück bei unserem video über
schlafentzug wo marcel von texas tisch
100 stunden wach war
grüße an dieser stelle habe ich las als
experten interviewt da er promovierte
biologe und schlafforscher ist und da
habe ich festgestellt dass lars nicht
nur sehr kompetent ist und wir total auf
einer wellenlänge sein sondern dass lars
zufälligerweise auch gerade überlegen
war
ob er von der forschung in die
wissenschaftskommunikation wechseln soll
und da hab ich natürlich gesagt wir
haben kekse seit januar 2009 10 ist lars
also mayrleb redakteur und ich finde
wenn man so zurückgeht und sich die
videos anschaut merkt man total ab wann
wir doppelt so viel not power hatten
dann klar es sind die videos also
nochmal deutlich besser geworden aber
entsprechend auch aufwendiger und da wir
als team an unsere grenzen stießen haben
es nochmal nach verstärkung umgeschaut
und ganz gefunden jens ist
mobiltechnologie er erforscht gerade
noch wie bestimmte hirnregionen bei
psychopathie oder depression anders
reagieren und das macht er an der
florida state university geht aber bald
nach deutschland zurückkommen und das
labor gegen meile tauschen ich feiere es
sehr dass wir dann drei promovierte
wissenschaftler sind biologe psychologe
und chemikerin sehr gute kombi wie ich
finde wir haben zum beispiel eine
gemeinsame whatsapp gruppe wo wir auch
viele sprachnachrichten hin und
herschicken und melanie nennt das schon
liebevoll ihren nerd podcast und die
vierte im bunde bin ich ich heiße mai
ich mache quasi die wissenschaftliche
redaktionsleitung ich mache die
produktion wie gesagt und ich moderiere
meine falls sie das noch nicht gemerkt
habt jetzt ist alles aber auch um klar
zu machen was alles hinter so einem
kanal steckt und dass man youtube nicht
unterschätzen sollte vielleicht sollte
man das als extra tipp aufhören da ich
ja auch im fernsehen unterwegs bin krieg
so beide welt mit die klassischen und
die neuen medien und gerade in den
klassischen medien denken viele ist ja
nur youtube jeder kann ja youtube video
hochladen ja irgendwann doch mal ein
youtube video hoch und schaut wie viele
menschen sich das dann anschauen da ich
bei funk bin habe ich wenig erfahrungen
mit dingen wie youtube werbeeinnahmen
oder sponsorships oder ding wie page
hören das ist ein privileg ich kann
entsprechend auch keine tipps geben ich
kann nur sagen wenn ihr creator gut
findet dann nehmt den kostenlosen inhalt
nicht als selbstverständlich hin sondern
unterstützt sie und für unseren fall
danke dass ihr den rundfunkbeitrag zahlt
sechs empfehlungen wird gern wissen von
dieser reichweite in die community
zurück geben deswegen gibt es jetzt hier
eine handverlesene liste von youtube
kanälen unter 100.000 abonnenten die
aber eigentlich viel mehr abonnenten
verdient werden
die habe ich euch auch alle unten in der
video beschreibung verlinkt neben links
zu größeren science kanälen die ihr
vielleicht auch schon alle kennt aber
ihr solltet trotz mal vorbeischauen
nur zur sicherheit nicht dass sie
irgendwelche wissenschafts inhalte
verpasst das wäre ja dramatisch hier nun
in keiner besonderen reihenfolge zehn
kleine bis mittelgroße kanäle die
eigentlich viel größer sein sollten
erstens lars fischer und sein format wir
werden alle sterben wo er
wissenschaftlich fundiert tödliche
themen durchleuchtet von corona virus
über
badus bis lepra hörnchen sehr witzig
sehr gut recherchiert und unschlagbare
themenauswahl 21 psychologie meine funk
kollegin pia mit dem café die nichts mit
küchenpsychologie am hut sondern euch
wissenschaftlich fundiert und sorgfältig
recherchiert psychologische forschung
erklärt und papier wurde auch von
melanie entdeckt drittens methodisch
incorrect methodisch indirekt ist der
sehr zu recht sehr erfolgreiche
wissenschafts podcast von nicolas wöhrl
und rainer trend fort kent man bestimmt
doch die beiden haben auch einen youtube
kanal wo es neben streams auch
experimente gibt hier ins transistor auf
sophia von transistoren die so heißt
weil sie siliziumkarbid bipolar
transistor expertin und elektro
trainerin ist wenig aufmerksam geworden
weil sie ein so großer mailath werden
ist dass sie mehrere videos über uns
gemacht hat wobei ich dann geraten habe
den content auszubauen weil mein content
dann doch eine etwas kleine nische ist
oder ich musste erst noch wachsen jetzt
mit einer millionen abos versucht es
nochmal in der end card verlege ich euch
ein video von ihr wo sie selbst versucht
hat das geheimnis unseres erfolgs zu
analysieren und zwar auf eine extrem
nötige art und weise die absolut keks
würdig ist fünfter
change wenn josef der change manager
produzent und filmemacher er ist
ziemlich vielseitig er hat einige
webserien auf dem kanal manche sich
manche sehr dass er macht selbst
experimente und zwar auf eine sehr
ungewöhnliche coole tolle art und der
einzige kanal in dieser liste mit über
100.000 abonnenten weil ich seit jeher
schockiert dass josef keine millionen
abonnenten hat bei dieser qualität die
er liefert die es auf youtube sonst kaum
geht nächstes roter zwerg das ist ein
kanal für euch freunde der sonne wenn
ihr euch für astronomie und
quantenphysik interessiert nein nicht
interessiert sondern wenn ihr es liebt
dann kriegt ihr hier wissenschafts
videos für fortgeschrittene die da oben
was ist eigentlich im bundestag los das
kriegt keiner so wirklich mit unseren
kollegen aline und jan machen einen echt
guten job bundestagsdebatten
unterhaltsam zusammenzufassen um mehr
aufmerksamkeit auf die wichtigen themen
zu lenken die uns ja alle betreffen
aber ihrerseits zu wenig aufmerksamkeit
für diesen kanal also vorbeischauen 8
und ranga yogeshwar wollen auch nie
braucht eigentlich keine beschreibung
macht jetzt auch youtube wer ihn schon
im fernsehen gut findet kriegt hier
quasi ranga pur
erzähl mir eine geschichte lars also
unser meile platz hat gerade elternzeit
und dabei ein kleines ganz frisches
neben projekt gestartet sein
vierjähriger sohn will nämlich am
laufenden band erfundene geschichten von
lars hören und die möchte las nun nach
und nach auf diesem kanal mit seiner
wunderbaren geschichten erzählstimme
teilen dass ich lasse in erster linie um
seinen jährigen sohn und ein baby
kümmern muss geht es ja erst mal langsam
vorangehen aber abo kann nie schaden ich
habe mitbekommen dass ihr einige junge
eltern zu schauen zehnte nina nina zeigt
euch wie man roboter baut zum beispiel
eine pflanze die dich an schreibt wenn
sie was er braucht oder eine sprechende
küchenwaage das erinnert mich ein
bisschen an zu bauen jetzt von der ich
auch fan bin die magd lina stil total
die vielen kameras person die ist er
aktiv auftritt und wenig auf youtube
aber die letzten beiden videos sind so
cool und ich würde so gerne mehr sehen
vor allem vom eigentlichen bauen und wer
weiß wenn ihr bei ihr vorbei schaut und
ganz lieb fragt vielleicht macht sie ja
auch mehr auf youtube aber moment bevor
jetzt da vorbeischaut und abos und kekse
hinterlasst noch nicht weggehen es gibt
noch ein paar wichtige leute die euch
etwas sagen möchte
hallo liebe freunde der sonne wie ich
nicht ehrlich gesagt oft liebevoll
gemeint verrückten also die verrückten
freunde der sonne einfach weil ich
regelmäßig fassungslos bilden was hier
in den kommentaren
es ist ja schreibt teilweise so
unglaublich lange tolle texte stellt
clevere fragen und das allerwichtigste
ihr lasst so unglaublich viel liebe da
und das motiviert uns unglaublich
gelassen attacken einfach nicht zu da
hatte dagegen dass es immer wieder so
unglaublich schön zu sehen und
sind einfach wahnsinnig dankbar für so
eine tolle kommenden jahrzehnte einfach
über eine freundin der sonne
das hätten wir uns damals als wir
angefangen haben mit schön schlau
niemals träumen lassen
tausend dank und ganz viele kekse mir
leute ich kann euch kaum sagen wie sehr
ich mich freue
ich habe so in der medienbranche schon
ein paar mal so aussagen gehört wie das
man wissenschaftliche inhalte jetzt
nicht so genau erklären könnte weil das
dann zu langweilig wird und dass die
leute nicht interessiert und wie
wegschalten hinten hier haben genau
darauf ob ihr habt ein video über
statistik in die deutschen youtube
trends gebracht die ihr interessiert
euch dafür was was man mit einem flott
machen kann und warum man neben benutzt
dann aber ist der unterschied zwischen
der prospektiven studie unter fall
kontroll studie ist und was da jeweils
die vor und nachteile sind wir
interessiert euch für die ja was ihr
wollt eben nicht die einfachen
simplifizierten und dann nicht mehr ganz
richtigen antworten sondern ihr habt
euch auch dann warum warum die
wissenschaft vielleicht zu dem thema
noch nicht die eindeutige antwort
liefern kann
man jetzt seid ihr eine million leute
ich finde es total geil ich für euch
ich werde mir heute meinen allerbesten
tee aufgießen
von den auf euch trinken liebe freunde
der sonne ich weiß nicht wie es euch
geht aber ich mache das immer sehr
glücklich und sehr froh zu wissen dass
sich der in der welt lebe wo wirklich
eine million menschen sagen ja ich will
gern regelmäßig neuigkeiten aus der
forschung
ich bin immer wieder was neues hören
über themen wo ich mich vielleicht gar
nicht auskenne oder vielleicht sogar wo
ich nicht auskennen und wissen dass da
die wissenschaft dazu sagt wo einfach wo
millionen menschen einfach neugierig
denn das macht glücklich und dafür gibt
es von mir ein ganz ganz großes
dankeschön kann mich nur anschließen
freunde der sonne wir sind sehr dankbar
eine community wie euch zu haben wir
sehen uns in zwei wochen und bis dahin
bleibt sicher